IS A MUSICAL >> Tucker: THE
LONG-TERM EFFECTS ARE HARD TO
KNOW EXACTLY.
RESTAURANTS AND HOTELS HAVE A
LONG ROAD BACK.
THAT’S CLEAR.
BUT WHAT ABOUT HIGHER EDUCATION?
THE NATION’S ENTIRE COLLEGE
POPULATION IS AT HOME RIGHT NOW
AT EXACTLY THE SAME MOMENT THE
ECONOMY SEEMS TO BE HEADING
SOUTH.
WHAT EFFECT WILL THAT HAVE?
WELL, THE FIRST THING TO KNOW IS
THAT WHATEVER HAPPENS NEXT, IT
WILL NOT AFFECT HARVARD, YALE,
STANFORD, AND A LOT OF PLACES
LIKE THOSE.
THESE PLACES ARE RICHER THAN
SOME COUNTRIES.
THEY WILL BE FINE WHATEVER
HAPPENS.
THE STATE SCHOOLS ARE LIKELY TO
WHETHER THE IT TOO.
FOR OTHER CAMPUSES, THIS IS A
LIFE-CHANGING MOMENT.
FIRST, ENDOWMENTS ARE LIKELY TO
SHRINK AS THE BROADER ECONOMY
STRUGGLES.
DONATIONS WILL DROP TOO FOR THE
SAME REASON.
THERE WILL MOST CERTAINLY BE A
REDUCTION FROM STUDENTS FROM
CHINA, THEIR ABILITY TO PAY FULL
TUITION.
AN ENTIRE NATION HAS JUST BEEN
SHOWN THAT IT’S POSSIBLE TO
DELIVER HIGHER EDUCATION IN THE
ENTIRE LEAD DIFFERENT WAY.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO DRIVE TO
CAMPUS IN ORDER TO GET AN
EDUCATION.
YOU CAN DO THE WHOLE THING
ONLINE.
THIS WON’T CHANGE EVERYONE’S
BEHAVIOR.
FAMILIES WILL CONTINUE ON AS
THEY ALWAYS HAVE.
250 GRAND TO SEND YOUR KIDS OFF
TO THEIR FRIENDS HAVE FUN FOR
YEARS.
TWO PEOPLE WHO CAN AFFORD IT,
THAT’S NOT SUCH A BAD DEAL.
CHEAPER THAN FOUR YEARS OF
TOURING EUROPE, WHICH IS WHAT
OUR RULING CLASS USED TO DO.
LET’S SAY YOU ARE NOT RICH.
MAYBE YOU MAKE $120,000 A YEAR.
THAT’S HIGH ENOUGH TO DISQUALIFY
YOU.
IT’S LOW ENOUGH THAT PAYING 30,
40, $50,000 A YEAR HURTS A LOT.
IF YOU ARE PAYING FULL TUITION,
THAT MEANS YOU COULD BE SEEN
HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
DEBT TO SEND A SINGLE CHILD TO
COLLEGE.
EVERY CHILD.
IMAGINE YOU’VE GOT THREE KIDS.
SOME OF YOU WATCHING DON’T NEED
TO IMAGINE THAT, BECAUSE THAT’S
YOU.
SUDDENLY, AN ONLINE EDUCATION
DOESN’T SOUND SO CRAZY.
YOUR KIDS WON’T LIKE IT AS MUCH.
HANGING AROUND A FRATERNITY IS A
LOT MORE FUN THAN STARING AT A
COMPUTER SCREEN.
IS THAT IT ON-SITE CUSTOMER YOU
MIGHT START THINKING ABOUT THAT.
YOU ALSO MIGHT BEGIN TO WONDER
WHAT A COLLEGE DEGREE IS WORTH
THESE DAYS.
A COMMUNICATIONS DEGREE FROM A
MID TIER LIBERAL ARTS SCHOOL?
TOTALLY AND UTTERLY WORTHLESS.
IT SIGNIFIES SUCH OBVIOUS
MEDIOCRITY.
COLLEGES KNOW ALL THIS OF
COURSE.
THEY ARE SELF-AWARE ENOUGH TO
REALIZE IT.
THAT IS WHY WASHINGTON IS
SWARMING WITH LOBBYISTS, SO THAT
CONGRESS WILL KEEP FUNDING IT AS
LONG AS POSSIBLE.
THE IMPOSSIBLE MAY HAVE JUST
ARRIVED.
THE CHARADE HAS BEEN EXPOSED.
STANFORD JUST KICKED STUDENTS
OFF CAMPUS AND STARTING CLASSES
ONLINE.
HERE’S THE AMAZING PART.
STANFORD ALONG WITH HARVARD AND
OTHER SCHOOLS LIKE THEM HAS
ALREADY ANNOUNCED THAT THEY WILL
NOT GET A SINGLE SENT DISCOUNTED
FROM THEIR TUITION.
EVEN MORE INSULTING AND
BAFFLING, REALLY, STANFORD
STUDENTS AREN’T EVEN GETTING
FULLY REFUNDED RENT FOR THE DORM
ROOMS THEY WERE KICKED OUT OF.
KEEP IN MIND THAT STANFORD HAS A
$27 BILLION ENDOWMENT.
THEY COULD AFFORD TO DO THIS FOR
THEIR KIDS.
THEY JUST DON’T WANT TO.
THEY ARE PAMPERED AND ARROGANT
AND INDIFFERENT TO THE SUFFERING
OF OTHERS.
AS NOTED, STANFORD, HARVARD,
YALE ALL HAVE ENOUGH CASH TO GET
AWAY WITH THINGS LIKE THIS.
BUT OTHER SCHOOLS DON’T.
UNLESS THEY CHANGE RADICALLY, A
LOT OF THESE PLACES ARE GOING TO
GO UNDER.
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH FEDERAL
BAILOUT MONEY IN THE TREASURY.
THEY WILL BE GONE FOR GOOD,
CLOSE, REPURPOSED, WE CAN HOPE,
INTO MUCH-NEEDED EFFICIENCY
APARTMENTS WITH LOADS OF GREEN
SPACE.
THEY WILL WAIL AND MOAN AT HOW
OUTRAGED EDITORIALS FOR NEW YORK
TIMES ABOUT THE END OF KNOWLEDGE
AND THE COMING DARK AGE.
YET, IGNORE THEM.
THESE PEOPLE NEVER DESERVED JOBS
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE HIGHER EDUCATION
ESTABLISHMENT IS HURTING THIS
COUNTRY AND IT HAS FOR A LONG
TIME.
REFORM IS ESSENTIAL.
THIS IS A GOOD AND NEEDED THING.